paychex ici c'est l'émission les
fonctions du coup on fait les choses
est-ce que ça a fonctionné kevin vatant
5 millions de télés sa master pas mal il
faut voir aussi avait une très grosse
concurrence ce soir la france 2 qui
était leader avec alex hugo à 5,1
millions de téléspectateurs étaient
faits un bracelet rouge à 4,3 millions
de téléspectateurs sur les ménages est
leader sur les sur les femmes notamment
de part de marché alors tf1
même les bracelets rouge qui était une
série qui va très très bien qu'il allait
très bien et ne fonctionne plus qu'est
ce qui se passe sur tf1
what happened tf1 ah bah il faut
chercher je le redis faut changer des
dirigeants puis à que rien ne marche sur
tf1 aujourd'hui les roues savoir si la
dernière si le fils pour moi j'adorais
mais on fait dans la fiction pour france
3 lui ses pattes f alors on va redire
sur pékin express avec des épreuves
on sent bien que sur m6 ils ont le sens
de l'économie les épreuves à l'année
dernière il mettait une corde une coop
cwa 4 15 15 1 euros là à l'élastique ils
sont pas emmerder les rails le jeu
budget de en prod c'est un euro
cinquante et encore sur les réductions à
regarder mais c'est un acte est un plus
oui les affreux
[Musique]
mais non je sais pas on affreux russe au
canada mes frères laroche
mais son poste
mais bon c'est drôle alors il ya eu il
ya une séquence qui nous a beaucoup fait
rigoler c'est vrai mais il ya encore des
gars qui étaient très très sûr la
candidature s'est fabriqué sur ingrid
hayes vraiment violent lui l'a fait
pékin express mais il était et treasure
double il voulait absolument attraper sa
concurrente dans les caniveaux
voilà c'est d'ailleurs séduit et ça veut
dire quoi attraper ça veut dire [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
ou alors soit c'est l'âge qui vous en
fait c'est en fait vous souffrez de
logorrhée m 1 et tout ça
et julien on dirait hibernatus pensais
qu'on parlait de l'amour est dans le
creux des bulles en parler de pékin
express c'est une hausse de 126 mais
téléspectateurs vous venez de man on
sait maintenant que les chiffres
annoncés dans mon émission médias et ça
c'est valoriser mon image sur balancer
des chiffres de merde bon pour ce très
haut niveau remercier notre démission
cette phase de brassage et là on l'a
découvert les corps qui nous regardent
c'est qu'on annonce dans l'émission
parfois prenez jean petit bout la pitié
d'eux à la suite vous faire créer mon
fils globalement vous aurez un truc n'y
avait pas assez sans merci
on va avancer parce que là c'est le jeu
c'est le journal était maintenant sur
pékin quand même non non non non des
chinois sur toi on va revenir on va
revenir on va revenir sur ingrid et sur
une grille
malgré de mauvais ménage non mais non
le cinéma c'est surtout après je compte
là était donc non pas en coupe mes
associés pour l'émission et lui fabrice
a vraiment envie d'attraper fc chooz
vraiment est-ce que tu t'attendais soit
6 me concentrer je répète pose des
questions elle comprend rien
tu vois ses envies de mettre une baffe
pour la réveiller sa nnsa non elle
absente signé son secours
voilà c'est même pas une pile qu'il faut
se mettre une fusée dans le fion
génomique ont présenté un carré enfants
fabrice info levitte
la lune de miel avec une grille dès
aujourd'hui elle est un peu mais elle a
un petit goût amer pour moi il mentir ou
là qu'il y ait quelqu'un peut coincer
[Applaudissements]